well hello there citizens of the reject Nation
Greg here hey John how are you I'm good man I'm
fantastic how are you sir in there was that
we're trying to do that was wrong okay ladies
and gentlemen if you could leave a like on this
video that'd be very much appreciated listen we
tried shooting this at the theater they wouldn't
allow it we tried shooting outside it was way too
dark you just wouldn't be able to see us we
try shooting in the parking lot at the movie
theater security guard there nice guy wasn't
a fan of what we were doing rushed back here
and uh now we're in the backyard shooting this
when we could be inside like pros in the studio
everything just a regular video but we wanted
to maintain some of the Integrity already just
watched video so as opposed to seeing it just
five minutes ago like we normally do now we've
seen it 20 minutes ago so it's not that big
of a difference it's a big difference John
since I know I got a lot to get off my chest here
what's the plot of the movie you know it's a few
years after end game Scott Lang is now an author
he's capitalizing on his his Avengers Fame but
his daughter Cassie Lang is a rebellious teenager
now she's Landing herself in jail which of course
is is just funny it's not a really big deal no
consequences to that so she's doing great she
builds this machine that accidentally gets them
all sucked into the quantum realm where Janet's
like no I hate it here and I don't want to
talk about it I want to tell you anything
about it for half the movie I'm gonna draw out
the suspense for something we already know is
coming and then Kang's here he's gonna set
up phase five and he needs some McGuffin so
he can break out of you know the quantum realm
and there's Shenanigans and stuff hopes in the
background here and there Hank is along for
the ride that's pretty much it alrighty look
there's a lot of things that I want to talk
about with this movie a good amount we can't
talk about that is non-spoiler there's a lot that
we can't talk about that is very spoiler heavy a
lot of those things that I take gripe with with
this movie that I imagine you do too because we
didn't talk to each other at all during the movie
no and what I was surprised by was when the movie
was done I was like ah great this is gonna
be one of those films where I'm going to be
arguing with John and he's going to be telling
me what he loves about it and I'm going to be
like oh no here's why I don't like this part
of the movie man oh wow to my surprise from
the brief time we talked about it we're I think
we're on the same page we had the same anxiety
I bottom line
overall it was fine and I know normally when
you say something like that people will yell
at you going why don't you just say it's bad
and what you want to say what you really feel
and I will tell you what I really feel I had a
lot of issues with this movie would it be a lie
for me to say that there weren't parts of this
movie that I did really enjoy I would even say
there's a solid 30 minutes of this film that I
was very much engaged with you know the part on
the trailers when Ant-Man and Kang meet each other
a little bit before that and like 20 minutes after
that there's a specific chunk of the movie where
I was like okay finally this movie's really it's
really got me I'm I'm in I'm really in and then
it started to lose me again and the finale of
this film especially started losing me I know
normally in reviews you want to like get all
the good points first and then you go into the
negatives it's gonna be this is going to be a
very serious discussion run in the middle of the
album it's good well yeah the movie's not exactly
like a three act or even a five act structure
it was like a 10x structure of this movie
most of it feels like act two somehow it's very
strange it's a paradox it is a paradox of sorts
okay so the first thing that people probably
want you to talk about right King the Conqueror
Jonathan Majors how is he well I can tell you that
I think Jonathan Majors did an excellent job with
the material that he was given I think he really
elevates the material it's really important for
me to emphasize the word Elevate I'm not exactly a
hundred percent thrilled about King the Conqueror
in total if that makes sense again a lot of it
to really describe it would be very spoilery I'll
just tell you some afterthought opinions I'm not
exactly thrilled at the prospect of Kang being the
uh big Baddie of phase five because while this
movie really seems to step out of its way to
not really be an Ant-Man movie a lot of time but
really set up phase five it does a great job at
setting up phase five it really does sure because
you're like all right at least get what phase five
is going towards I can see threads coming together
I can see Clarity like you mentioned when we came
out of the movie there's some clarity from phase
four coming into this especially a lot of visual
motifs and some lines of dialogue where I'm
like I'm even seeing some of phase four actually
clicking together so they must have heard all
the complaints people were having or like make
sure this [__] is clear they live service to
interconnectivity here making it clear while I
think he brings a lot of Gravitas to it the way
they execute the character and what they give
him to do in this film I didn't find him scary I
thought a lot of what they chose to do with his
movie really undercuts him as a threat I really
think Scarlet Witch could I think if you watch
this movie I I don't feel like there's a question
in your mind that you'd be like Scarlet Witch
could whip this guy's ass yeah so why would I be
excited about like The Avengers having to deal
with this guy because this movie also goes out of
its way a lot to be like he's hyper intelligent
he's so smart he's so threatening he's unspeakable
movie never really shows you despite the fact that
when he is talking it is the most engaging Yet
the movie never really gives you an insight as
to how and then the way the movie progresses
I'm like this guy this is the dude you've been
building up for so long it was also going gonna
have his own Dynasty later yeah that's probably
gonna be the most unpopular opinion out there
because I'm sure everyone's raving because again
he does a great job no it's the rest of the movie
the writing and the direction doesn't necessarily
bolster it doesn't help his performance more
than he's helping out everything else around
him and on top of that that creates this sort of
teetering between what could be a real formidable
villain who presents a harrowing set of stakes
versus something that starts to feel a bit
like a costume party that's turned angry the
mid-credits scene I bet if we go online right
now there's a lot of people hyping up this mid
credits yes there are there are you looked I've
seen a few responses and I've seen people be
like oh man that made credit scenes scene was
a joke it like feels quite silly if I were to
tell you what it is contextually you'd be like
awesome that's what I was hoping for yeah
contextually the way it's executed was
like an SNL sketch to me meets the ending of the
Planet of the Apes movie with Mark Wahlberg it's
not like that ending but it has that Vibe of that
ending like I think it's real cool it's supposed
to be like really cool and serious and setting
something up and I'm like this is just so so
silly and people were laughing in the screening
where we're at I bet not at the movie premiere
they weren't laughing but at the screen we were
rap people you couldn't hear any of the dialogue
to know over the cheering I can't wait to talk
about it because that was a really cringy I mean
credits yes that's a good way to put that yeah it
does feel like they rented out a warehouse for an
afternoon and tacked something on well that's
supposed to be the major punctuation on this
movie and yeah it feels very much like it must
have something to do with Spider-Man yeah I like
it it does give you that sort of stilted vibe
I mean the post-credits scene is good yes it is
ruin it but it's obviously
Peyton Reed didn't do it
yeah it's a bit detached from the immediate
proceedings that was what elicited the most
from the audience in a lot of ways it is one of
the most interesting moments the entire movie
gives you is at the very end of the credits with
this film there's there's no real struggle and I
don't mean that just emotionally there's no real
conflict the most engaging way for for most movies
is if there's an external struggle and they have
to like go through it and then they change as a
person like how does this experience of going
toe-to-toe with the villain change them as an
individual what do they have to overcome there's
none of that in this movie that's a movie that
on Surface might be like this is the weirdest
MCU movie ever it's about as old Marvel generic
as you can get there's not a lot of stakes in
this movie feel like it feels like they really
prioritized plot over everything else and setups
over everything else in a way that makes it feel
like there's a ton going on there's lots of stuff
happening and yet not much is really achieving
any kind of momentum it keeps Shifting the plot
around there's like 10 acts in this movie I never
really had time to get invested in something
enough to worry about it to fear for it to be
concerned about it and then when they finally
set up a plot that you see kind of teased in
the trailer I'm like okay well we're now we're at
the end of the movie it really feels like Peyton
Reed's desire not to be the palette cleanser movie
and to instead be the Avengers level movie has
really worked against it because on the one hand
I feel like that could equate to some interesting
strides for the Ant-Man Trilogy and it doesn't
funny enough feel like the third installment in
the Ant-Man Trilogy really at all making it this
Avengers level set of stakes kind of took a lot
of the personality and a lot of the actual scope
and scale like if you look back on the previous
Ant-Man movies this doesn't need to be that but
it's tempered by the real world and the changing
of size of familiar objects the this almost does
none of that and it also pairs down the humor and
I feel like you could have made an Avengers level
movie with that level of impact out of Ant-Man and
use that as an opportunity to hoist a a more
B level or less successful character into the
main Spotlight this is the most I've felt like the
VFX team did just direct the movie based off the
notes that whatever the interconnectivityness like
required and Modoc Modoc is the thing that I feel
will be really hated I don't hate Modoc in this
movie I think I kind of enjoyed him he's one of
the things I like more and is actually a bit weird
about the movie it's weird it's like when it first
is presented you're like that is it's awful this
is a weird looking they play into it in the script
in the actual reactions from the like they react
more to Modoc than they do anything else in this
one seriously they react more to him because he is
weird he's got the Dead Eye effect old CGI and I'm
like but maybe that's intentional I I don't know
he's not threatening he's not scary whatsoever
he is just a joke but he had two moments in this
movie two specific lines of dialogue I could think
of those were some of the funniest I laughed in
the whole film absolutely as much as I know this
character will definitely upset people he made me
laugh that was one of the most intentional things
about this movie was to not take him seriously
and they didn't take him seriously and then they
leaned into that I know there's going to be a lot
of people who don't like it and will think it's
one of the worst things Marvel's ever done but
screw it at least something intentionally was like
yeah at least I laughed at that you know Paul Rudd
is good uh as always he's good he's Paul Rudd he
gets more dramatic work to do here than he did in
any of the other films we've seen him do and I I
thought he was believable in those moments Cassie
Lang I like Katherine Newton the actress uh quite
a bit and I'm not gonna lie I imagine there'd be
a lot of people with a lot of problems with her
again it's one of these situations where I'm like
I enjoy Catherine Newton there's so much about the
execution in the writing the storytelling of this
character wow what a convenient experience this
movie is so full with visual effects but there's
no sense of awe or wonder okay let's look at Hank
pin I get if you've seen some [__] and he's not
like exactly he's entirely thrown off base but he
should be at least a little fascinated by what's
going on so should wasp but especially Cassie
laying there should at least be some sense of
a horror glim Steven is a smidge of what this
world could be beyond our own yeah yeah Beyond
just having Yellow Jacket come into her room
and then five year disappear because the quantum
realm is nothing like that's a whole different
thing yeah yeah yeah you just gotta sucked through
a Vortex into the atoms beneath atoms you should
at least have a reaction to that and beyond
that neither John or I are a fan of this phrase
I'm going to have to say it though because I
can't really think of anything more efficiently
to describe it at this moment in time there is
the Mary Sue effect that people often say where I
normally don't agree with its application of that
word I'm like yeah it's it's reasons like this why
why this word exists yeah because the truth of the
matter for me is it's not even like I got annoyed
it was like I could feel the movie removing
opportunities for itself to have impactful
character moments with Cassie and with Scott
together and her growth as a character because
too it's the first time we're seeing Cassie in
this capacity as a potential young Avenger and
stuff like that and it's the first time that we're
getting to witness her you know experiencing all
this stuff and yet the movie Maneuvers her into a
place where everything's just cool and she's just
kind of got this and No Matter What conflict
comes her way everyone around her is like nah
you're fine it's fine you're good even Scott with
his minor disciplinary dad dude just is a cool you
know the trailers really made it seem like that it
was something about I really want time with my my
daughter back King's giving me an offer that's the
way the trailers pitched it yeah that's not the
movie they set you up like Cassie and and Scott
must have like a strained messed up relationship
or something he's been gone and she's fallen on
the wrong path man oh you're like not really he's
gonna walk pretty well so with that there's no
character Arc in this movie at all it's pretty
much Scott has not been doing heroic stuff lately
now he's doing something heroic yeah yeah it's
been a while since the last Avengers level threat
now Scott has a new Avengers level threat Janet
they're setting her up for she's got to confront
the demons from her past but that kind of just
gets no she needs to hold on to Exposition until
it's time to give it out it just gets completely
lost in the mix they lose a lot of opportunities
for multiple characters to have actual emotional
beats and arcs and it's funny because I've seen
a lot of people respond to this thing it's such
a heartwarming father-daughter story and that's
all I was hoping for it was a surface cute level
yeah like I said everything went to the fine level
like you just don't know what to care about you
get thrust into the quantum realm and you see that
in the trailer they got all this like Civilization
of people and stuff they just keep saying [__]
like Kang's bad he did stuff to our people and I
think there's like a line in there that says what
he did the movie never lets you get to actually
know these people and a big part of it is wanting
to start an uprising in a revolution so you don't
feel for it why would I care they even have this
setup in here where Scott is like we just got to
get out of here but Cassie's like no Dad we gotta
help these people and you never get a moment the
slightest spoiler I'm gonna give you is you never
get a moment where you see Scott being like you're
right we gotta help you we owe it to these people
yeah whatever becomes about that but it becomes a
focus of the film but I'm like I never got to
know these people I don't know why I should
care about this the movie just shows you a lot of
like weird designs of the quantum realm you don't
really get to know the quantum realm and they
keep seeing Kings in like this oppressive thing
when you go around the city it looks like you guys
are living a regular normal lives like the worst
the Kings got are these security guard Androids
which suck by the way they are ineffective how
is this the Master Level scientist guy when he
builds the weakest henchman because he has no
formidable challengers in this realm that's why
he's revered as this crazy warlord is because
there's no competition they don't show you the
occupation and they don't really give you any
taste of what life is like down here under this
oppression or what the oppression even looks like
or extends to I know that that's the cliche you
have a big Baddie got a bunch of henchmen who
you just kick and punch I know that's a cliche
but this is the guy who they've been saying is
this highest level intellect genius but I'm like
Ultron did better in a day then all this time
you've been here banished out here for decades
upon decades it's not difficult to keep up with
I really feel like the movie just needed like an
extra 30 minutes just so we could have some much
needed scenes to help these emotional moments land
more otherwise it's just another movie where a lot
of people walk away from going like yeah cool
action and it sets up phase five well really I
think a lot of the best Marvel movies are always
setting up the future of Marvel but that's only
a percentage of the film where this seemed like
its main intent was to set up the future I wasn't
personally like yeah people often complain about
green screen heavy movies but this really stood
out to me because as impressive as the visual
effects are there are scenes like when they
especially when they first go into the quantum
realm one thing I'll get paid and read credit
for was I love the choice of when to use music and
when to not use music because a lot of the times
these movies could be quite bombastic with music
to really try to enhance the experience but a lot
of the time there was no music and I thought
that was better and it made a lot of the sound
design zeroed in a lot better for a lot of these
key sequences because all the visual effects are
great that scene where you see multiple Ant-Man
and stuff what a cool sequence it was a fantastic
sequence it was amazing occasionally a few wonky
moments of what movie would not have some wonky
VFX once in a while it's as great as visuals can
be that stuff can wear thin after a while because
it just starts becoming like a lot of noise the
thing that I felt the most that this movie was
was like I was standing in line for an Avengers
ride and then they had these like special clips to
watch while you're waiting in line and I had the
feeling like oh cool they got the actors to show
up for this but you know when the actors show up
for that [__] they're not giving it their right
Everything feels a little more green screeny in
one of those Riot videos and here even it feels
like everyone's just kind of in a big Warehouse
with a bunch of Animation around them and even
the way that it's shot is kind of that like ah
we didn't really have that much time so just
keep it into basic coverage and some basic wide
shots and that's about it as cool as everything
looks it seems to lack again I keep using the word
Wonder it's easy to just say style over substance
but that's really what it is this style is is the
people who created the visuals and created the the
the the makeup and stuff that's the style somehow
this movie does not make you make you feel lived
in it does not feel immersive there's no emotional
struggle and there's no physical struggle and
that's a big problem I think with Peyton Reed
directing the actors or just not knowing what
to do for example if you're running through chaos
and everyone's just running like they've been told
to run they got like a straight face like just
like you don't look like you're in the middle
of a battle or in the finale no spoilers these
are just humans and they're zipping around town
freaking fighting left and right running running
running and then by the end of the fight when
the storms calm down you know helmets come off
or whatever they just look like super clean no
breathing heavy not a single sweat they're just
like super polished and yeah we're standing in
front of a green screen doing our scene there's
no weight either emotionally or physically the
hand-to-hand fight that you see in the trailer
with King and and but that's the most physical
struggle that takes obviously a long time to get
there it finally gets bloodied up and that does
look intense and painful yeah too little too
late but the big thing though is this is the
first Ant-Man movie with this cast that you're
bringing over and paid in redirecting that is
primarily in front of a green screen a big part
of why especially there were no stakes and this
was something I did not expect to say about this
film I felt there was no Stakes or no sense of
urgency really came down to some of the
performances in this film Michael Douglas
as Hank Pym is not the same Hank pin at all like
it feels like some random old guy who was told
all his lines before they said action there
was so much of the time where it was clearly
obvious that they didn't know how to direct direct
people like Evangeline Lilly and Michael Douglas
because they clearly had no clue what they were
looking at yeah and a lot of even the continuity
character-wise from the previous movies doesn't
fully carry over it feels like Hank Pym got like
a Xanax prescription and chilled way out between
movies or something like that and yeah Evangeline
Lilly her job is mainly just to be flustered
a lot of the time and maybe deal a punch it's
called Ant-Man and the wasp and I'm like you
should just call this Ant-Man and King she's
called Ant-Man Cassie the king you guys are easy
to call this movie of all the ant family hope
does feel the most tacked on in the least sort of
spotlighted like Michael Douglas was I was kind
of astounded by how he was just walking through
the film because I really feel like what's going
on the performer who got more screen time this
time around and I thought did a great job and
was the one who actually brought intensity
who actually seemed comfortable working in
this environment was Michelle Pfeiffer as Janet
obviously she had been in the quantum realm for
quite some time and her character set up in
a way where she's very much traumatized from
her experiences there so she doesn't want anyone
exploring in the quantum realm but I did have a
thought when I was watching this because she's so
much like you shouldn't be looking in this evening
I'm near it but then I was going I thought in
the post-credits scene for Ant-Man and the WASP
she was totally sending Scott Lang in there
into the quantum realm to collect energy to
help ghosts stabilize herself through the quantum
tunnel continuity wise this doesn't even line up
with the last time I saw this woman it doesn't
even make any sense right now but let's ignore
that for a moment it sets up her character in this
way to like overcome and see like what really went
down here I actually really like the flashbacks
that you get to see with Janet I thought they were
really strong and very engaging that was part of
the 30 minute chunk that I was talking about where
you do really get to explore some of that and
I thought that was really engrossing there is
humor in it like there were times I really laughed
but a lot of times the humor feels like they're
afraid to commit to the overall seriousness of
a particular moment so they're trying to inject
some humor sometimes it's genuinely funny
a lot of the time it does have that clear
cut effect of they felt like they needed to infuse
a joke in here when they didn't need to infuse a
joke don't get me wrong there are some there are
some moments where I was like that was hilarious
there's a couple moments where I thought were
really really funny yeah it was fine it's another
fine evening I would not call this movie terrible
it's definitely not a glowing but the brightness
does make you especially frustrated I think I
think it's one of those where it's pretty okay
in a way that leaves you really kind of aggravated
by all the potential that was very visibly missed
yeah because I think part of the burnout that
some people probably feel after phase four is
like a lot of phase four I think for the most part
A lot of it isn't isn't terrible it's just a lot
of it is kind of like I kind of suffered thinking
about it once it's done and I was like this movie
should not be doing that no at least and you know
what we're pretty big marbles so this is the Prime
movie especially for me as a viewer this is the
Prime movie where I want to go in and just have
fun with it and look past any whatever flaws to
the things I love about an Ant-Man movie and the
excitement for Kang to come and it fumbled that
that so I was especially taken aback because I was
like this should have been an easy slam dunk on me
as a viewer same here I I really thought that this
would have easily been yeah I got some flaws we'll
go into them but mainly here oh here's everything
I thought it was gonna be like the easiest
thing to talk about but I was like this really
surprised me just how middleweight beautiful
was it's reasonably enjoyable throughout this
is not the best I could give it with some
moments that really truly shine but anyway
all right well we're done see
you guys thanks for being here